[Music]
the Great Wall this is hey youtubers
Game of Thrones is almost here so HBO
has finally started promoting it you're
going to see more and more promos like
this coming in the next couple of weeks
but a lot of you have requested a video
about ice dragons do they exist so I'm
going to explain what the books say
about them as well as how it's possible
for the TV show to do them there are a
lot of theories I change the audio just
a little bit so let me know if you think
the audio for this video is a little bit
better than the previous videos that
I've been posting the last couple of
days so a lot of you have been asking
about an ice dragon and Game of Thrones
it's been mentioned a couple times
George our Martin even wrote a short
book that's sort of non canonical to A
Song of Ice and Fire called the ice
dragon but then later it shows up during
old Nan's tales those always have
elements of truth to them and then
surprise surprise when world of Ice and
Fire came out they actually spoke of ice
dragons in a more literal context like
oh this is probably a way to explain all
this crazy phenomenon that's going way
up in the Shivering sea there is a new
round of the game of Thrones giveaway
because we're getting so close to the
season coming out I'm going to start
making it for HBO now subscription so
you can just watch the show on demand
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so this appears in a chapter that's just
about the geography of the East they're
talking about the Shivering sea which is
this area north of Essos which nobody
has done a good job of mapping in speak
of as most sailors are afraid to go
beyond the thousand Isles most of the
legends arise from sailors trying to
find really quick passages through the
north so that they can go to the other
side of the world down to the summer sea
it's just another way to take advantage
of trade make that much more money but
nobody has been successful so far this
would be one of those challenges to
throw at the feet of Euron Greyjoy
he's boasted that you've seen more of
the world sailed more of the world than
anyone else but maester Margate speaks
on and says of all the clear and
fabulous denizens of the Shivering sea
however the greatest are the ice dragons
these colossal beasts many times larger
than the Dragons of Valyria are said to
be made of living ice with eyes of pale
blue crystals and vast tree
and loosed wings through which the moon
and stars can be glimpsed as they wheel
across the sky whereas common dragons if
any dragons can truly said to be common
breathe flame eyes dragons supposedly
breathe cold a chill so terrible that it
can freeze a man solid in half a
heartbeat sailors from half a hundred
nations have glimpsed these great beasts
over the centuries so mayhaps there is
some truth behind the tales Margate has
suggested that many of the legends of
the north freezing myths ice ships
cannibal bay in the light can be
explained as distorted reports of ice
dragon activity though an amusing notion
and not without a certain elegance this
remains the purest conjecture as ice
dragons supposedly melt when slain no
actual proof of their existence has ever
been found then the rest of that
material just goes on to talk about the
other sea life up in that area talking
about big whales that live there just
other large sea creatures then later
during dance with dragons Jon Snow
starts remembering the old man tales
about an ice dragon old man told them a
lot of tales especially about the
night's king which we've now learned is
a little bit different on the TV show
they call him the night king just I
think to make a little bit simpler in
Georgia are Martin has distinguished
that the mythical Knights came from old
man's tale the 10th Lord Commander is
somebody who died a long time ago so
based on the evidence the show has given
us there is an element to truth to old
man's tales but obviously it ends up
being much different in practicality a
couple years ago most people just used
to wonder whether or not brand would be
able to fly as the three-eyed Raven told
him using a dragon would he be able to
ward a dragon something that big because
if he can ward a human being like Hodor
which is an incredibly difficult thing
to do even someone with a simple mind
like Hodor
then now that he's one of the most
powerful people on the planet shouldn't
he also be able to do the same thing to
one of Daenerys his dragons George R
Martin got asked this all the time
usually his answer is that there was no
precedent for it he wouldn't say no he
wouldn't say yes he's very good about
that
so given the level of his power as
produced by this show I say that he can
warg one of the Dragons although it's
not quite as simple as working someone
like Hodor so the newest theory
now is that the night Cain will actually
ride a nice dragon after one of Daenerys
dragons falls in battle there's a lot of
Hoops that he had to jump through to get
there first
why would Daenerys have dragons in the
frozen north this suit maybe that's
something that's more likely during
season eight when they are full-on war
for the dawn and they've stopped their
petty Wars down in the south but just
looking at the trailer footage Jon Snow
in a band of wildlings and other people
have gone to the lands of always winter
to try and do something white Walker
related so there's going to be scenes up
in that area it's possible that Daenerys
could take a dragon in somatically I
think the books have actually been
setting Daenerys up for a big fall she's
been invincible so far the TV show flows
a lot from that it's actually made her
more invincible than book Daenerys is
but her real power lies in her dragons
so how do you take power away from her
you kill one of the dragons there's a
number of ways to do it but if you're
going to do it with magic there are only
a couple of people to have power that's
great enough what you know you can have
an incredibly large force just try to
attack the dragon before they were
roasted alive to someone like bran or
the knight king could try to control it
with their magic there were magical
horns that the Valyrian is made to
control dragons euron greyjoy has one of
the books we haven't seen it on the TV
show yet but there's also the horn of
boys winter that's said to be able to
bring down the wall which also sounds
like it has roots in Valyria so being
that it looks like Jon Snow is trapped
in the frozen north there are plenty of
opportunities for Daenerys to come try
and rescue him for a dragon to be lost
in the attempt and if bran is powerful
enough to warga dragon then the knight
king is certainly powerful enough to
raise one like he would any other white
the book speak of giant ice spiders from
the last long night as well as giant
bears that have been turned into white
so there are very large animals in the
past that have been raised as whites by
the White Walkers in the night King so
let me know in the comments do you
actually feel like that's a direction
that this show would go it feels like a
big TV style WTF moment you've never
seen this before
you saw dragons were awesome what do you
think about a dragon that's raised as a
white and ridden by the night king in
the battle making him seem that much
more invincible somatically it makes a
lot
cents because what happens if John Snow
in Daenerys make an alliance and they're
able to also quell what's going on down
in the south with Cersei they would be
almost unstoppable with three dragons
so what threat could be big enough to
challenge them even the growing army of
the Dead which is massive could be mowed
down by three dragons just lighting them
up we haven't seen a real genuine aerial
dragon battle since the dance of the
Dragons which was almost 170 years
before the events that are happening on
the show right now so there are just a
lot of practical and thematic reasons
why it's possible for Dragon to be
raised as a wight and why that would be
an important challenge for Daenerys and
Jon Snow's Alliance going into season
eight so let me know in the comments do
you actually think that we're going to
see a dragon raised is a white before
the show goes off the air either the end
of season seven or during season eight
sometime it just feels like an
inevitability something that would be so
cool to pay off even if it's not exactly
what George R Martin had in mind but I
feel like all the work that he's done
with the Song of Ice and Fire
teasing the idea of ice dragons as well
as teasing the idea of white Walker ice
spiders this is all manner of crazy
creatures that we just have not seen in
present-day because remember nobody
thought the Dragons would come back when
the show first started during book 1
they talked about the last dragons dying
out long ago but then surprised dragons
are born again and you start seeing more
and more magical phenomena getting
crazier and crazier shadow babies Jon
Snow coming back from the dead so it
just keeps escalating and I can't wait
to see what they do with it on the TV
show this season so leave all your
requests for Game of Thrones bonus
videos in the comments below I'll be
doing more and more as we get closer to
the season we're probably not going to
see more footage for a little while but
a lot of you have been requesting a
Tyrion video so that'll probably be one
of the next one but congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Rohan Patel
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round of
this video I'll just announce the winner
the next time I post a game of Thrones
video while you wait for that click here
to learn all about the new map theory
from the trailer and you can click here
for my full trailer breakdown thank you
so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys tonight
you